[Musique]
cette programmation militaire ne propose
pas une rupture fondamentale avec notre
modèle historique au contraire elle
propose à sa manière d'y revenir dans sa
force conceptuelle initiale c'est-à-dire
dans sa capacité à s'adapter vite en
prenant en compte les défis du monde
actuel et donc comme menace sécuritaire
actuelle ainsi qu'Auto technologique que
j’évoquais qui emmène avec eux
inévitablement des sauces stratégiques
ou tactiques dont le champ de
l'hybridité à cela s'ajoute la nécessité
d'articuler ces nouveaux domaines de
lutte autour notre dissuasion et de nos
capacités expéditionnelles
bonjour et bienvenue sur LCP pour ce
nouveau numéro des grands débats trois
lettres LPM comme loi de programmation
militaire il s'agit pour les députés de
voter la trajectoire budgétaire des
armées pour les années 2024 à 2030 mais
aussi de débattre des priorités de la
Défense nationale une question majeure
alors que la guerre a fait son retour
sur le sol européen depuis l'agression
russe en Ukraine
[Musique]
veut et même doit faire seul et ce
qu'elle veut ou doit faire à plusieurs
en 2017 le budget de nos armées était de
32,3 milliards d'euros cette année en
2023 le budget des armées de 43,9
milliards d'euros c'est donc une marge
de mentation de 11,6 milliards d'euros
par rapport à 2017 sans compter les
crédits qui ont été votés en gestion à
cela il faut donc intégrer 1,5 milliards
d'euros pour c'est encore moins courant
une surexécution budgétaire en 2027 date
qui intéresse beaucoup à la fin du
second quinquennat du président de la
République le budget des armées sera de
56 milliards d'euros soit une marge
d'augmentation de plus 23,7 milliards
d'euros il aboutira en 2030 à un budget
de 68,9 milliards d'euros or pension qui
aura donc plus que doublé le budget des
armées de la France en l'espace de deux
lois de programmation militaire lors du
retour de la guerre en Europe de
l'agression russe en Ukraine de la
stratégie de puissance de la Chine ou
encore de la multiplication des menaces
hybrides chacun d'entre nous a
conscience de l'importance du rôle de
nos armées pour faire entendre la voix
de la France
les mots du général de Gaulle sont
toujours d'actualité lorsqu'il disait la
France ne peut être la France sans la
grandeur
en sentant lui aussi avait été confronté
à des bouleversements géopolitiques et
technologiques majeures décrié par
certains lorsqu'il avait choisi
d'investir massivement dans le nucléaire
militaire au détriment d'autres
investissements
l'histoire lui a donné raison
aujourd'hui mes chers collègues l'enjeu
est de continuer d'assurer à la France
son autonomie d'analyse de décision
d'action et de lui conserver son statut
de puissance d'équilibre et de nations
cadres
soyons les fervents défenseurs de nos
valeurs soldats qui fidèle à leur
histoire et aux valeurs de l'armée
française sans prêt si la réussite de
leur mission les y oblige à aller
jusqu'au sacrifice suprême au moment où
je vous parle j'ai une pensée émue pour
noblesser et nos morts pour la France et
je sais que chacun de vous s'associe à
cet hommage j'ai reçu
de notions de rejet préalable dépose un
application de l'article 91 à Ina 5 du
règlement la parole est à Monsieur
Fabien Roussel
[Applaudissements]
madame la Présidente Mesdames les
ministres monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues
décider d'engager 413 milliards d'euros
pour nos armées pendant les 7 prochaines
années est un sujet extrêmement sérieux
important et c'est d'ailleurs pour cette
raison que nous avons déposé une motion
de rejet pour la simple et bonne raison
que nous demandons solennellement que
ces choix fassent partir d'un large et
grand débat avec tous nos concitoyens
toute la société bien au-delà de notre
assemblée d'abord parce que cette loi de
programmation militaire implique une
stratégie au service de l'OTAN que les
Français doivent connaître vous défendez
monsieur le ministre vous venez de le
dire une autonomie stratégique pour la
France où est cette autonomie
stratégique depuis que la France a
rejoint le commandement intégré de
l'OTAN nous souhaitons pour notre part
nous retirer de ce commandement intégré
et retrouvé pleinement notre autonomie
stratégique si cher au gaullistes et aux
communistes et nous sommes fidèles à
cette histoire-là ensuite
parce que ce budget va atteindre 69
milliards d'euros par an en 2030 69
milliards d'euros à l'heure où votre
gouvernement demande énormément
d'efforts à nos concitoyens y compris en
leur demandant de travailler plus pour
financer notre système de retraite 69
milliards ce qui en fera et cette inédit
sous la Cinquième République le premier
budget de l'État devant celui de
l'éducation nationale pour lever tout
ambiguïté sur la position des élus
communistes et du groupe GDR nous sommes
très attachés à l'indépendance et à la
souveraineté de la France en matière de
défense et même d'industrie de défense
nous sommes de ceux qui voteront toutes
les dépenses permettant d'augmenter ses
moyens les moderniser permettre à nos
soldats de s'entraîner de se protéger
d'être les plus efficaces sur le terrain
la défense nationale ne se négocie pas
elle doit être forte et efficace nous
allons donc maintenant procéder au
scrutin je vais donc mettre au voile la
motion de rejet préalable je vous prie
de bien vouloir regagner aux places
le scrutin est ouvert
le scrutin est clos
voici le résultat du scrutin votant 185
exprimé 185 majorité 93 pour 27 contre
158 la motion de rejet préalable n'est
pas adoptée
l'effort budgétaire de défense
concernant cet LPM il faut le
reconnaître et au rendez-vous
413,3 milliards sur 7 ans c'est une
somme plus que substantielle cependant
il faut aussi il est important
relativiser certains effets d'annonces
et nous avons eu l'occasion de le dire
en commission je pense notamment à
l'inflation et à l'exécution annuelle de
cette trajectoire qui sera il faut le
reconnaître un défi cette loi de
programmation militaire porte une vision
de la France de sa place dans le monde
et répond à la question quel modèle
d'armée pour demain
petit retour en arrière d'abord 3
décennies de sous-investissement avec
conduit nos armées au bord de
l'effondrement par la précédente LPM
notre majorité avait renversé cette
tendance en engageant une politique de
rupture qui mettait enfin un terme à
l'érosion de nos forces armées cette
ambition s'est traduite très
concrètement par une augmentation du
budget de la mission défense puis par
une exécution budgétaire que dis-je une
surexcution budgétaire uneaniement
saluée autant de gages de confiance et
de crédibilité pour cette nouvelle loi
de programmation nouvelle car le retour
de la guerre à haute intensité à nos
portes en Ukraine sur le sol européen la
guerre hybride mondialisée
l'accentuation des tensions
internationales ou encore les multiples
défis globaux justifie que nous
répondions sans attendre à ces
bouleversements de notre environnement
stratégique j'ai durant la dernière
campagne longuement développée ma vision
de cette France puissance en ce début de
discussion je me satisfais que l'outil
militaire que vous programmez pour les
prochaines années ne soit pas
incompatibles avec la politique
étrangère et de défense que je souhaite
mener l'actualisation prévue dans ce
texte permettra d'ajuster notre outil
militaire quand nous arriverons au
pouvoir le contexte géopolitique
économique dégradée nous oblige à faire
de cette LPM 2024-2030 un texte
irréprochable sur le plan de la
sincérité budgétaire comme sur celui des
capacités militaires monsieur le
ministre vous avez réaffirmé le rôle
majeur de la dissuasion nucléaire et en
cela nous vous soutiendrons sans réserve
nul ne serait remettre en cause l'un des
piliers de notre défense
héritage du gaullisme car l'existence de
la France en tant que pays libre n'est
pas un acquis mortel et doit toujours
être défendu sur le plan conventionnel
en revanche nous inquiétudes demeurent
certes les efforts entrepris depuis 2015
sont louables et ont permis de mettre un
terme à la saigner infligé aux armées
dans le cadre des dividendes de la paix
des années 90 mais ils ne sont toujours
pas assez rapides et surtout pas assez
massif budgétairement cette indépendance
retrouvée nous permettrait de proposer à
toutes les nations qui le souhaitent
notamment européennes de nouvelles
coopération s nous devons relancer des
discussions pour un nouveau traité
faisant de l'espace un bien commun de
l'humanité nous devons œuvrer pour la
mise en place d'un droit international
du cyber nous devons œuvrer dans le
respect du Traité de Non proliférations
au désarmement nucléaires multilatéral
des puissances dotées et détentrices
cette ambition n'est pas contradictoire
avec le fait de réaffirmer
qu'aujourd'hui la dissuasion de
nucléaire demeure la clé de voûte de
notre défense nationale mais si la
dissuasion reste crédible aujourd'hui
quand sera-t-il demain qui peut nous
garantir que la dissuasion nucléaire ne
sera pas un jour notre nouvelle ligne
Maginot quel dirigeant responsable
pourrait affirmer aujourd'hui que dans
30 40 60 ans la dissuasion nucléaire
sera infaillible car avec les ruptures
technologiques dans l'espace dans les
fonds marins dans le cyber dans le
domaine de l'hyper vélocité il se
pourrait que notre dissuasion soit
contournée ce risque même un film il
n'est pas acceptable de s'y exposer et
d'y exposer la nation dès lors nous
devons l'anticiper il faut explorer
toutes les pistes d'action dissuasives
crédibles y compris non nucléaires c'est
pourquoi nous proposons de créer un
commissariat à la dissuasion de demain
elle sera peut-être spatiale cyber ou
autre ne nous payons pas de mots ce
n'est pas une loi historique c'est une
loi raisonnable pouvons-nous nous en
satisfaire l'essentiel est sauf la
dissuasion nucléaire clé de voûte de nos
intérêts vitaux qui permettent de
calibrer tout le reste et bien assuré
les grands programmes sont préservés la
préparation de l'avenir et la
compétitivité de notre BITD nécessaire à
une future remontée en puissance sont
prises en compte même si il est
certainement possible d'aller plus loin
pour notre souveraineté industrielle
face au dilemme mascohérence vous avez
privilégié la cohérence et ses bienvenus
il ne sert à rien d'avoir des matériels
dans les hangars sans pouvoir produire
les effets pour lesquels ils ont été
conçus mais nos forces conventionnelles
demeureront partiellement
échantillonnaire dans notre mission sur
la haute intensité nous avions chiffré
les manques à 40 milliards ce trou n'est
pas comblé car nous avons à faire face
aux nouveaux champs de conflictualité
spatiale cyber grand fond que nous
n'avions étudié qu'à la marge cette loi
y répond est plutôt bien cependant je ne
renie rien de ce que j'avais écrit la
masse n'est pas totalement au
rendez-vous
mais la défense est globale il n'est pas
de défense forte sans économie saine il
n'est pas d'économie forte sans financer
pour reprendre les mots du général de
Gaulle la politique et l'économie sont
liées l'une à l'autre comme le son
l'action et la vie et nous savons tous
hélas l'ampleur de nos déficits la dette
c'est la faiblesse le risque du chantage
de nos créanciers au pire le scénario
grec alors il faudra bien faire avec
cette enveloppe pour la deuxième fois de
suite l'examen de la loi de
programmement de la défense et de la
sécurité nationale la revue nationale
stratégique qui fixe le cadre de
l'élaboration de la présente loi navite
aucun parlementaire à participer à son
élaboration à sa réflexion et l'analyse
précise et approfondie nécessaire à
notre politique de défense vous aimeriez
sans doute comme beaucoup être perçu
comme un héritier du général de Gaulle
force et de constater que vous en
retenez surtout la pratique du domaine
réservé malgré vos propos rassurants en
commission et l'adoption d'amendement
qui infléchissent votre premier
mouvement
vous participez à conforter la mise à
l'écart du Parlement en matière de
défense pourtant lorsqu'on London à
entendre de tels montants il est
absolument nécessaire de débattre
régulièrement et publiquement des enjeux
qui nous préoccupent en matière de
défense voilà qui renforcerait le lien
armé nation qui vous préoccupe tant
plutôt que la mise en place de
dispositifs coûteux à l'image du ssnu
aujourd'hui nous n'avons plus le choix
et le réveil est brutal à cause de notre
aveuglement la moitié de l'humanité
connaît au moins une fois par Andre
grave pénurie d'eau 3,3 milliards de
personnes vivent dans des zones déjà
vulnérables au changement climatique et
entre 8 à 30% des terres agricoles
mondiales pourraient devenir un
cultivable nous sommes confrontés aux
limites de notre terre et au risque de
conflits que cela implique alors oui il
est nécessaire de garantir les dépenses
qui permettraient à nos armées de
fonctionner que cela soit par
l'amélioration des conditions de travail
et de rémunération mais également par
l'investissement dans le maintien aux
conditions opérationnelles des
équipements ainsi des efforts réalisés
sur ces sujets sont pertinents car aussi
puissantes soient-elles une armée doit
d'abord se penser à hauteur d'homme et
de femmes
garantir le bon fonctionnement de notre
armée comme de tout service public et
nécessaire mais dans un monde
profondément incertain une noix de
programmation militaire ne peut se
contenter d'additionner les oraux elle
doit impulser une vision stratégique de
notre défense et anticiper les conflits
de demain malgré les grands mots
d'amplification de transformation c'est
LPM s'inscrit dans la continuité et
surtout ne prend pas en compte la
complexité du monde d'aujourd'hui et
encore moins l'imprévisibilité de celui
de demain j'ai suffisamment alerté au
cours de mes mandats précédents sur la
baisse de notre effort de défense pour
ne pas aujourd'hui me réjouir de voir
cette loi de programmation militaire
consolider notre force de dissuasion
vitale et réarmée notre pays
cependant ce n'est pas parce que vous
faites mieux que vos prédécesseurs qui
ont désarmé la France que vous n'avez
pas encore et que nous n'avons pas
encore une marge de progression
le coeur de la loi de programmation
militaire c'est une enveloppe globale de
413 milliards d'euros pour les années
2024 à 2030 un budget en forte hausse
par rapport à la loi de programmation
militaire précédentes 413 ou 400
milliards d'euros l'article 3 du projet
loi de programmation militaire montre
une enveloppe globale de 413 milliards
d'euros mais le tableau de ventilation
indique lui le chiffre de 400 milliards
d'euros où sont passés les 13 milliards
d'euros manquants sont-ils garantis
c'est précisément ces questions que les
oppositions posent au ministre qui
répond très longuement
[Musique]
413 milliards ou 400 milliards
la question demeurée le ministre en
adoptant en faisant adopter en
commission un amendement présenté par
Olivier marlex d'une certaine manière
sécurisée c'est 13 milliards de
ressources extra budgétaires en
garantissant des ressources budgétaires
au cas où ces ressources extravitaires
n'auraient pas pu être
mise à disposition
maintenant il manque un amendement du
Gouvernement nous attendons l'amendement
du Gouvernement qui va transcrire cette
garantie dans la programmation parce que
le tableau du troisième alinéa de
l'article est toujours sur un total de
400 milliards donc nous sommes dans une
loi de programmation nous avons besoin
de savoir quand c'est 13 milliards de
ressources supplémentaires vont être
utilisés vont être affectés parce que
c'est avec cette vision là que l'on
saura précisément où l'on va d'abord
quelque chose que je n'ai pas compris et
puis après je vais vous expliquer ces
amendements je n'ai pas compris les
propos de la France insoumise qui
demande dès maintenant que soit budgété
la somme des 413 milliards moi je n'ai
pas compris que le ministre nous avait
dit qu'il renonçait aux ressources extra
budgétaires ce qui nous a été dit c'est
que dans l'hypothèse où les ressources
extra budgétaires
ne serait pas à la hauteur des 13
milliards prévus pour respecter le
critère
physico-financier ce serait compensé par
le budget de l'État à partir de ce
moment-là s'il ministre est sincère sur
les ressources extra-budgétaires sur
lesquelles il compte et je ne doute pas
qu'il soit sincère on verra si l'en plus
il est lucides et si les faits lui
donner raison mais si il est sincère il
n'y a pas de réseau que ce soit budgété
en tant que tel ou alors on est
complètement à côté de la plaque et je
n'ai rien compris en tout cas si on
regarde les 13 milliards d'euros ensuite
parce que moi je pense qu'il faut que on
soit clair sur cette affaire une bonne
fois pour toute alors après non je me
reprends non ça sera jamais une bonne
fois pour toute parce que la réalité
c'est que dans toutes les
reprogrammations militaires on a jamais
montré les ressources extra budgétaires
jamais montré les marges frictionnelles
ou report de charge et moyennant quoi
c'était comme quoi c'est pas toujours
non plus un encouragement la
transparence il y avait jamais une
question sur le sujet il a fallu qu'on
le montre pour que tout le monde se
passionne et que celles et ceux qui
parfois avaient voté des crédits
budgétaires en diminution pour les
forces armées ces dernières années se
réveillent en disant ah oui mais c'est
intéressant mais comment ça est-ce que
c'est 13 milliards existent vraiment
comment ça fonctionne bon alors je vais
refaire pour la 75e fois la
démonstration sauf que comme par
sympathie pour Monsieur saint tout le
dans c'est toujours son anniversaire ce
soir je vais en profiter pour donner des
chiffres par chronique sur ces 13
milliards d'euros ce qui permettra
monsieur Thiriot d'informer le président
marlex qui semblait inqui est
visiblement de la qualité de l'étude
d'impact de cette loi de programmation
militaire et qui a pu nous le redire à
nos nombreuses reprises cette semaine
sur ces bancs de 2024 à 2030 nous avons
une chronique de recettes propres au
ministère des armées qui reposent sur un
segment d'aide à l'Ukraine que vous
connaissez j'ai déjà expliqué détails
après je peux aussi recommencer trois
mois de débat parlementaire mais enfin
s'il le faut je le ferai les recettes
extra budgétaires dont les recettes
patrimoniales et les recettes du service
de santé des armées je pense que tous
les commissaires à la défense sont enfin
définitivement au courant de cette
affaire là on est sur une somme de 7,1
milliard d'euros pour la période il se
trouve que les sessions immobilières
sont celles qui souvent ont été décidées
dans le passé donc on va avoir beaucoup
de recettes au début ça veut dire qu'on
a la chronique suivante nous tablons
c'est à dire les services de Bercy et
les services du ministère des armées et
puis je le dis tout de suite s'il devait
y avoir une prévision qui serait pas
forcément comment dire
réaliste ou réalisée nous aurions
évidemment le mécanisme que le président
que Monsieur Thériault le présenterio a
fait
a fait voter en commission de la défense
première année en recette extra
budgétaire en 2024 1,7 milliards d'euros
2025 1,3 milliards d'euros 2026 1,3
milliards d'euros 2027 809 millions
d'euros ça descend essentiellement liée
aux recettes et encore les soulignes
s'il le fallait c'est notamment lier aux
sessions immobilières 2028 649 millions
d'euros 2029 630 millions d'euros 2030
629 millions d'euros ça ce sont pour les
recettes
une fois de plus financement Ukraine
dont à partir de 28 évidemment les
crédits de paiement sont à zéro pour les
raisons qu'on comprend vous avez les
crédits de paiement sur les premières
années qui correspondent du matériel que
nous avons pu donner là aussi je l'ai
suffisamment expliqué par ailleurs
ensuite on a les ajustements de dépenses
marche frictionnelle et variation de
report de charge qui par définition sont
importants en début de période je
rentrerai l'inflation après parce que ça
aussi je veux dire c'est le seul
ministère de la République pour lequel
on s'inquiète de l'inflation manque de
bol c'est le seul ministère dans la
République qui a des outils pour le
gérer mais enfin ça c'est un autre débat
il se trouve qu'en début de période on a
un ajustement des dépenses qui en 2024
de 3,7 milliards d'euros en 2025 de 2,4
milliards d'euros en 2026,5 milliards
d'euros en 2027,5 milliards d'euros
2028,6 milliards d'euros et ensuite la
tendance est négative en 2029 en 2030
évidemment c'est logique c'est le
renversement moins 1,1 milliard d'euros
- 3,6 milliards d'euros tout ça
évidemment étant conforme et fait fond
pardon 13 milliards d'euros
ce qui a toujours existé dans les lois
de programmation militaires précédentes
mais curieusement personne
n'interrogeait Florence Parly où
Jean-Yves Le Drian ou
Gérard Longuet Hervé Morin ou d'autres
bon donc je le dis quand même pour
mémoire pour celles et ceux qui ont
encore le netteté intellectuel d'avoir
un peu de mémoire merci monsieur le
ministre pour ce cadeau vous nous a fait
la démonstration de votre brio il y a
aucun doute là-dessus et
vous avez bien noyé le poisson
parce qu'en réalité ce que vous nous
avez dit c'est comment vous obteniez ces
13 milliards de ressources extra
budgétaires dont acte ils existent tant
mieux mais vous nous avez toujours pas
dit comment vous allez les dépenser vous
nous dites il y a un besoin mais vous
mais oui mais année après année est-ce
que ça veut dire que vous allez dépenser
en 2024 1,7 milliards grâce aux sessions
en 2025 1,3 milliards bien sûr que non
c'est pas ce que vous allez faire
il y a donc pas d'affectation budgétaire
donc ça veut dire que on a pas de vrai
programmation parce que vous avez d'une
certaine façon et pour répondre à notre
collègue Thiriau vous avez sanctuarisé
13 milliards mais vous n'êtes pas en
mesure de les dépenser
non vous avez peut-être réservé une fois
pour la soif je ne sais pas mais cette
poire pour la soif elle fait 13
milliards c'est-à-dire que on a quelque
part dans le dans la programmation
budgétaire un deuxième PNG ça fera
plaisir à notre collègue l'arseneur
peut-être on a un deuxième PNG qui est
en train de se balader quelque part
voilà c'est ça
si si vous ne nous dites pas quand vous
allez dépenser cet argent alors il ne
sera pas dépensé ou alors vous
vraisemblablement vous le garder pour
faire face à l'avenir
non ça n'est pas dans la 1 ou alors nous
sommes très très mal comprenant mais
vous voyez je crois que nous avons bien
compris la manœuvre vous nous parlez des
marches après 2027 nous faisons nous
nous faisons pas de procès sur celui-là
vous nous expliquez que le report de
charge serait de la ressource ça c'est
intéressant si je vous comprends bien
alors le report de charge vous pensez
utiliser le report de charge pour
encaisser l'inflation mais si c'est pour
encaisser l'inflation facilement
l'expression triviale vous lissez
l'effort mais ça ne signifie pas que
vous compensiez la perte de pouvoir
d'achat que représente l'inflation
donc vous avez bien 13 milliards qui
vont flamber pour rien
donc vous ne les dépensez pas vous avez
bien 13 milliards de besoins qui ne vont
pas être affectés besoin
un autre point du texte à occuper les
députés le montant des marches les
marches c'est la hausse du budget des
armées année après année certains
députés estiment qu'il faudrait répartir
les forts autrement
effectivement il nous semble que cette
trajectoire est soumise à beaucoup
d'aléas on doit reconnaître qu'au moment
où ça a été préparé peut-être ne
pouvions nous pas
imaginer la forte inflation que nous
avons que nous vivons depuis maintenant
de nombreux mois mais nous devons aussi
réessayer de réaliser les objectifs de
cette loi de programmation militaire si
jamais elle était votée et en
l'occurrence il nous semble qu'il serait
pertinent finalement d'inverser cette
trajectoire puisque en réalité à
l'instar de l'actuel loi de
programmation l'augmentation des
ressources budgétaires et plus fortes à
la fin de la période couverte voilà
alors évidemment on l'a dit avec la
flexion finalement on risque d'arriver à
une stagnation il faudrait pas que ce
soit une baisse puisque nous ne
pourrions là pour le coup absolument pas
remplir les objectifs de cette loi de
programmation donc ainsi que la
souligner dans son avis le Conseil
d'État tous les chiffres présentés
au-delà de 2027 sont affectés de
nombreux aléas et donc nous souhaitons
remplacer le tableau proposé par celui
que nous vous proposons en inversant
exactement la trajectoire de cette
programmation budgétaire merci madame la
députée merci madame la Présidente bon
quant à notre groupe rassemblement
national nous proposons une trajectoire
budgétaire différente des ressources de
la mission défense entre 2024 et 2030
hors charges de pension et à périmètre
constant nous pensons que les efforts
d'augmentation de crédit de paiement
doivent se faire dès la première année
de la loi de programmation militaire
pour répondre aux besoins urgents de nos
armées afin qu'elles remontent plus
rapidement puissance il est également
indispensable de contrebalancer les
effets de l'inflation qui restera selon
les projections macroéconomiques fortes
en 2024 en l'état les crédits pour 2024
ne diffèrent pas de ce prévu par la loi
de programmation 2019-2025 en cours
d'exécution ce qui est difficilement
justifiable au vu de la hausse de
l'inflation que personne ne conteste ici
ainsi le gouvernement évalué les effets
de l'inflation pour la mission défense à
30 milliards d'euros de pertes sur la
période 2024 2030 cette estimation
pourrait selon le Haut Conseil des
finances publiques être encore plus
élevé réhaussée en raison de
l'augmentation du coût des matériels
militaires la loi de programmation des
finances publiques prévoient une
stabilisation de l'inflation à côté de à
compter de 2025 autour d'un objectif de
2% ce qui rend d'autant plus nécessaire
un effort précoce sur les marches
budgétaires cette trajectoire proche de
celle proposée par le gouvernement
permet néanmoins de garder des marches
relativement hautes sur les dernières
années de la LPM 2024 2030 afin
d'anticiper les dépenses liées au
programme décalées dans le temps du fait
de cette LPM il y a
cet argument surprenant de les grosses
marches sont l'essentiel des marches
sont après 2027
alors ça c'est sûr c'est pratique pour
faire une conférence de presse entre
midi et deux en une demi-heure mais
quand on regarde les chiffres de plus
près c'est un peu plus difficile à tenir
et pour cause puisque nous sommes en
2023 et que nous avons déjà fait une
marche à plus 11,6 milliards d'euros par
rapport à 2017 on reviendra à
l'amendement de Monsieur Bayou qui a
raison parce qu'au moins il est cohérent
je ne suis pas d'accord avec lui mais
considère que c'est certainement
beaucoup d'argent on y reviendra que au
début de LPM en 2024 on sera plus 14,7
milliards d'euros qu'en 2027 on sera
donc à 23,7 milliards d'euros et qu'en
2030 on sera à 36,6 milliards d'euros
bon ça veut dire que ce qu'on appelle
l'essentiel des marches vous avez entre
2017 et 2027 c'est-à-dire les 10 ans de
présidence d'Emmanuel Macron et de
présence dans cette missile de la
majorité présidentielle vous avez une
marge de plus
23,7 milliards d'euros c'est à dire les
deux tiers c'est sûr que ces
minoritaires deux tiers
suffit de compter et entre 2027 et 2030
parce que il y a une élection
présidentielle
oui il y a une élection présidentielle
et donc là c'est une marge de plus 12,9
milliards d'euros alors
l'argument qui consiste à dire aussi ce
sont les mêmes marches parce que ça fait
trois à chaque année c'est évidemment
méconnaître la toute la construction
physique qui a été faite au début
et puis
très accessoirement si dans un escalier
il vous prenait l'idée de marcher sur la
même marche vous ne montriez pas
l'escalier madame la députée pour être
très clair pour reprendre votre argument
de tout à l'heure et donc ce sont des
marches qui se cumulent et c'est
d'ailleurs bien là le sens de la
cohérence de l'amendement de Monsieur
Bayou c'est qu'en fait ça fait beaucoup
d'argent en cumulé parce que c'est pas 3
milliards d'euros en plus chaque année
ces 3 milliards d'euros en plus par
rapport à l'année -1 ce qui est tout
d'un coup quand même fait des volumes
importants puisque ça nous amène à faire
un X2 alors même en faisant x 2 on a
quand même le commentaire que avec
l'inflation tout ça serait au fond
stagnant alors là ça continue d'être
assez surprenant pour tout un tas de
raisons déjà
l'inflation est dans la copie là aussi
ça doit faire 40 fois qu'on le dit il
est dans la copie parce que précisément
je viens de vous donner les chiffres des
reports de charge
mais si vous faites non mais si si enfin
je veux dire ou alors vous ne comprenez
pas ce que sont les rapports de charge
bon donc si vous le comprenez même la
députés ce que je vous crois bien
volontiers c'est pour ça que je vous
soupçonne davantage de faire de la
politique plutôt que de ne pas
comprendre pour être transparent avec
vous ça sera dit c'est que
j'en fais un peu mais moi j'assume je ne
prends pas des argument technique
fallacieux donc quand j'en fais j'assume
vraiment bon quand vous avez des outils
dans ce ministère pour gérer justement
l'inflation alors que faut-il faire sans
servir ou ne pas censé servir alors si
je comprends bien dans les amendements
et dans l'explication de vote et du PS
et du rassemblement national parce que
vous avez employé le même argumentaire
oui mais nous c'était avant l'aflation
bon très bien on a toujours pas
forcément compris d'ailleurs pour quel
contrat opérationnel ou quel modèle
d'armée ou alors c'est celui qu'on a
proposé plus ou moins au moins c'est
déjà plus cohérent et je l'accepte bien
volontiers ça reviendrait donc à prendre
les variations de report de charge et
les transformer en crédit budgétaire en
clair vous prenez les 2,6 milliards de
report de charge en 2024 et donc ce que
vous proposez c'est de les prendre en
crédit budgétaire non mais moi ça serait
cohérent et vous dites 0 par deux
charges
en fait il y a de manière de traiter
l'inflation je pense qu'il faut qu'on se
le dise mais pour la mémoire des débats
là aussi une bonne fois pour toute soit
on se sert des outils et le report de
charge en étain comme il a toujours
existé on peut être pour on peut être
contre soit on prévoit du crédit
budgétaire nouveau mais pardon la bonne
gestion et tout celles et ceux qui ont
été élus locaux le savent très bien
quand on a un outil comme le report de
charge sur des masses aussi importantes
sur des programmes aussi importants par
on s'en sert ou alors faut être mauvais
gestionnaire
donc le problème et c'est ce qui
m'étonne depuis le début quand j'ai vu
un certain nombre de sensibilités
politiques se jeter sur les marches et
sur la chronique budgétaire sans
vraiment l'avoir travaillé c'est que je
me doutais bien qu'on aurait cette
conversation à un moment donné par
quelques boucs vous la preniez la copie
qu'on vous présente elle est cohérente
ça va même tellement plus loin que la
plupart des amendements je sors
l'amendement Bayou groupe écologie parce
que il a sa cohérence politique parce
que c'est pas le même projet politique
c'est mon qu'on puisse dire c'est que à
force de vouloir à tout prix mettre de
l'argent avant 2027 pour essayer de
créer l'idée qu'au fond la majorité
telle réelle l'effort ah oui c'est sûr
vous parlez de parler d'un étalement
d'effort vous voyez des sommes dont on
parle que vous vous retrouvez sans le
vouloir ou sans faire attention
à présenter des amendements qui
diminuent le budget des armées en 2029
en 2030 ça veut dire qu'en année pleine
une fois qu'on a terminé les
augmentations vous avez dans la liasse
d'amendement une deux trois 4 5 6
amendements qui se veulent sur le papier
avec un exposé des motifs pour dire on
va augmenter le moyen des armées si
amendements qui sont en dessous de la
cible à 69 milliards d'euros que la
majorité propose alors moi je vous fais
je peux demander une suspension de
séance et une deuxième lecture du
rapport annexé en 2029 2030 quels sont
les bateaux que vous supprimez parce
qu'à 67 milliards d'euros pour certains
66 pour d'autres et encore ces chiffres
sont plus près de la vérité que ceux de
la commission puisqu'ils ont tous changé
suite mettre différentes remarques que
j'ai déjà pu faire en transparence en
commission ou parfois certains budgets
tombés à 63 ou 64 milliards d'euros quel
programme vous décalez assez puis un
étalement là ça pour le coup ce sont des
annulations quand il vous manque un demi
milliards d'euros en terminaison sur la
plupart des amendements qui sont déposés
il faut m'expliquer comment ça
fonctionne donc moi je veux bien que on
s'entraîne à la copie du gouvernement
parce que c'est celle du gouvernement
c'est du président de la République
parce que c'est celle du président de la
République à celle de la majorité parce
que c'est celle de la majorité Dieu sait
qu'on peut raconter n'importe quoi
parfois avec des mots avec des chiffres
c'est un peu plus difficile et un peu
plus compliqué et donc de fait la
trajectoire qui est proposée non
seulement elle correspond aux besoins
physiques pour les armées telles
qu'exprimées dans le rapport annexé que
nous venons d'examiner en tout cas j'ai
pas entendu de changement tel de modèle
d'armée qui modifierait des choses de la
volonté de mettre de l'argent plus vite
pour elle s'entendre s'il y avait une
volonté assumée parmi vous d'acheter sur
étagère y compris à l'étranger c'est sûr
que si on regarde pas du tout les rues
en version souverain on peut directement
acheter des imams à l'année prochaine
augmenter les marches mais c'est pas du
tout ce qu'on s'est dit depuis le début
de la semaine donc je pense aussi qu'il
faut qu'on l'assume avec cohérence ou
alors faut le démontrer sinon ça ne
fonctionne pas pareil pour les
infrastructures peut rajouter un
milliard d'euros de plus si vous voulez
l'année prochaine vous n'aurez pas pour
autant les infrastructures qui iront
plus vite ou un porte-avions de
nouvelles génération qui sortira plus
vite des Chantiers de l'Atlantique ou un
sous-marin nucléaire qui sortira plus
vite des chantiers pour autant donc
comme on arrive à la fin du raisonnement
bah oui je terminerai et en disant et en
plus c'est compatible avec la
trajectoire des finances publiques mais
je termine la démonstration par là et je
ne l'ai pas commencé par ici ce qui me
semble important
après une lecture à l'Assemblée au Sénat
une commission mixte paritaire se réunit
cette députée et cette sénateur qui se
mettent d'accord sur un nouveau rythme
des dépenses un effort budgétaire plus
important que prévu entre 2024 et 2027
ce qui permet un effort plus régulier
sur l'ensemble de la loi de
programmation militaire la loi de
programmation militaire prévoit un
effort sur le recrutement avec
l'ouverture de 6300 postes d'ici à 2030
et 700 dès l'année prochaine objectif
000 personnels de défense enfin de LPM
pour renforcer le lien entre les armées
et la nation cette loi prévoit de porter
la réserve opérationnelle à 105.000
femmes et hommes d'ici à 2035 le but
c'est d'avoir un réserviste pour deux
militaires d'actifs
[Musique]
nos armées ne valent que par celles et
ceux qui les servent
il me paraît utile de rappeler qu'en
2016 il y avait
266 792 et TP
qu'ils seront en 2027
271 800 et qu'ils seront en 2030
275 milles c'est-à-dire que la
progression ne TP dans nos forces armées
en civiles et militaires sera de plus
8708 personnes depuis 2016 on a donc
évidemment stopper une déflation
dangereuse qui a touché nos armées
pendant très nombreuses années
ajoutons les 105.000 réservistes et bien
nous arriverons à la fin de cette loi de
programmation militaire un effectif
total de 380
000 hommes et femmes dans les évolutions
que vous proposez à cet article
effectivement il y a pas de distinction
selon les différentes armes donc ça ça
fait peut-être partie des questions que
nous aurons et puis ce qu'on observe
aussi vous avez cité mon cher collègue
et 267
000 UTP ce qui est vrai
mais il y a une grosso modo 60 000
contractuels et puis 207 000 à peu près
militaires qui ont statut de militaire
et on voit que sur les personnels qui
ont vraiment le statut militaire il a
alors je parle pas des années 2008 et
2009 où il y avait effectivement il y
avait des chute importante des effectifs
mais sur les récentes années on voit que
c'est soit stable soit ça a tendance à
baisser et donc c'est ce or c'est
effectivement le cœur d'une armée
opérationnelle j'ai associé évidemment
les contractuel mais effectivement ce
qui mène les opérations ce sont des ce
sont des militaires cet article nous
donne les objectifs en matière
d'augmentation des effectifs mais il y a
deux observations à faire la première
est que dans la LPM en cours les
objectifs n'ont pas été atteints pas
tous été atteint et donc évidemment même
si on peut se retrouver sur les
objectifs de l'article 6 on doit avoir à
l'esprit le retard d'une certaine façon
accumulée lors des dernières années et
puis il faut aussi préciser comme l'a
dit ma collègue rabot il y a quelques
instants que un article 6 qui nous donne
des cibles d'effectifs à un niveau aussi
général
et quand même manque un peu de
transparence à l'égard du Parlement
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
allons faire nous une proposition
d'amendement qui ne sortira pas nulle
part évidemment mais qui proposera
d'entrer plus finement dans le détail
afin que nous puissions savoir
exactement au fil des années si les
objectifs sont
le le ministre et c'est conseillé ont
forcément planifier les embauches vu que
ils ont programmé les crédits
nécessaires sur les 7 prochaines années
autant l'inscrire dans le marbre de la
loi vu que de toute manière il est prévu
à la fin de ce même article une
souplesse sur la réalisation ou la
répartition de de ces embauches donc
inscrivons dans dans la loi les
objectifs cela me permettra de
d'indiquer des orientations et ensuite
libre au ministère et de réaffecter en
fonction des besoins mais je me je pense
qu'il est utile
d'inscrire dans dans la loi les les
objectifs comme c'était déjà le cas dans
les dans les LPM précédentes
pourquoi c'est pas dans la loi en tant
que tel bon déjà ça crée une forme de
rigidité sur un domaine qui me
semble-t-il relève véritablement la
gestion de l'employeur public il y a
beaucoup de sujets sur lequel on a
légiféré sur lequel on a inscrit on a
écrit des sujets enfin des choses dans
la loi vous allez me dire bon enfin la
réalité qu'est-ce qui fait qu'à 20 30 TP
40 TP ici ou là souvent d'ailleurs ce ne
sont même pas des sujets qui me
remontent mais que le séma peut gérer ou
le SGA peut gérer ou le DGSE peut gérer
à son niveau c'est d'ailleurs aussi une
démonstration par l'inverse c'est que si
nous avions été si vous aviez été trop
précis en 2018 et un certain nombre de
ventilation de TP nouveau pour la DGSE
qu'on n'aurait pas pu forcément donner
ces dernières années sur lequel on
regarde des circonstances on a
évidemment pris des décisions de
correction donc moi je reste persuadé
que la responsabilité aussi
ministérielle des grands directeurs
d'administration centrale sous le
contrôle du ministre qui endosse la
responsabilité c'est aussi de procéder à
ces répartitions là qui ont pu être
ajustés avec le temps donc avis avis
défavorable peut-être un amendement au
fond qui est un amendement d'appel sur
le degré de transparence de sujet
vis-à-vis du Parlement mais qui est un
autre sujet à la rigueur c'est programme
et à l'ETP près qui on met à la DGA ou à
la DGSE au passage ça serait inédit
parce qu'il y a pas un autre ministère
même sous votre programme dans lequel on
est rase degrés là je suis un parallèle
la loopsie à la rigueur le travail de
l'exécutif c'est de dire au Parlement
bah voilà le cyber va être un axe
d'effort donc on va mettre l'essentiel
des efforts en matière de TP dans le
cyber ça c'est le dialogue naturel entre
le Parlement et l'exécutif mais
commencer à fléchir le TP près c'est pas
tant que c'est une rigidité c'est que là
pour le coup je pense qu'on va au-delà
même de ce qu'est la programmation et on
gagne pas en efficacité en tout cas les
exemples de l'exécution de LPM actuelle
montre bien que cette cette souplesse
est plutôt la bienvenue dans ta vie de
retrait ou défavorable au cas échéché
monsieur le ministre j'entends vos
j'entends vos arguments
c'est vrai que le tableau qu'on vous
propose est très précis il est vrai que
le vôtre il est beaucoup moins il existe
peut-être une voie médiane qui aurait pu
nous rassembler
malheureusement elle n'existe pas et
vous n'avez pas fait d'amendement du
gouvernement pour être un petit peu plus
précis que les très grandes masques que
vous avez inscrit dans le que nous
allons inscrire dans la dans le marbre
de la loi donc monsieur le ministre
j'entends ce que vous nous dites
entendez que le Parlement souhaite plus
d'informations également cet amendement
souhaite attirer votre attention sur une
question de grande importance pour
l'équité la représentativité et
l'efficacité de nos forces armées celle
de l'égalité professionnelle entre les
femmes et les hommes de la défense
aujourd'hui malgré les avancées trop
lentes réalisées en matière de parité le
plafond de verre reste une réalité
persistante dans nos armées les femmes
ne représentent que 10% des officiers
généraux nous ne pouvons plus
ignorer cette disproportion notre groupe
propose un amendement visant à renforcer
l'égalité professionnelle et à augmenter
la féminisation de la défense notre
objectif est clair faciliter l'accès des
femmes au diplôme d'état-major et
atteindre une départ de femmes parmi les
officiers généraux situés à 20% d'ici
2030 cela représenterait un effectif de
50 femmes officiers généraux contre
environ 30 actuellement en outre en
augmentant la présence de femmes à tous
les niveaux dans notre armée nous
renforcerons l'attrait de la carrière
militaire pour les jeunes femmes
contribuant ainsi à l'objectif de
fidélisation du personnel présentée par
cette LPM la difficulté d'amener des
quotas pour au grade de général ça
serait assez difficile parce que parfois
alors déjà il faut aller sur le
recrutement initial parce que le nombre
de
représentations de femmes dépens aussi
du recrutement donc là comme je vous le
disais 98 c'est pas si vieux que ça et
si vous faites le calcul et bien on a un
certain nombre de femmes qui sont
présentes mais qui sont issus de ce
quota là qui était très réduit donc
première difficulté et une autre
difficulté c'est la présence des femmes
dans certains corps je vais vous donner
un exemple
ou le service de santé ou on va
retrouver des armées où on va retrouver
peut-être beaucoup de femmes si on dit
10% on risque de de se retrouver en
difficulté par rapport à d'autres
d'autres branches désarmées un défi
majeur sur lequel je tiens à rendre
hommage à Florence Parly parce que elle
est la première ministre en charge des
armées à s'atteler à l'effort la
difficulté qui est rencontrée c'est qu'à
la différence des autres fonctions dans
l'état pour être général il faut avoir
été sous-lieutenant plus lieutenant plus
capitaine puis commandant puis autant
colonel puis colonel et enfin être
proposé au général avec ces deux étoiles
c'est pas le cas des autres fonctions ou
la notion de tour extérieur vous permet
a permis de féminiser un certain nombre
de corps et de créer des conditions
d'égalité plus rapide donc en fait ça
personne ne propose raisonnablement
d'idées on a dû le débat en commission
c'est logique le métier des armes
correspond à un cursus qui est qui est
qui est propre aux armées et que
personne ne souhaite voir remettre en
question donc en fait le vrai débat on a
commencé à l'avoir la semaine dernière
ici même c'est évidemment le vivier
initial et en fait il y a quelque chose
évidemment qui est très déséquilibrée
c'est si votre sortie de l'école de
l'air à Salon-de-Provence de
saint-circuit de pour la remettre terre
et de l'École navale pour ne citer que
ces trois-là mais enfin on pourrait
aussi élargir à politique après tout
pour pour la DGA ou autre si vous ne
créez pas plus de Viviers initiaux chez
celles qui sont aspirantes puis sou
lieutenant très mécaniquement vous vous
retrouvez avec un vivier de capitaine de
vaisseau et de colonel trop faible pour
proposer au général ça c'est la première
difficulté la deuxième il faut la
regarder et j'ai demandé une analyse
précise de cette affaire c'est que sur
pas beaucoup de femmes ayant été promu
général le de brigade ou Contre Amiral
général de division ont parfois quitté
les armées plutôt que prévu avant la
date de liquidation de pension ça c'est
quelque chose qu'on a qu'on a regardé
sur les quatre dernières années qui moi
évidemment m'interpellent on peut pas le
balayer d'un revers de main et j'ai donc
chargé une mission particulière d'une
femme générale elle-même d'ailleurs de
regarder d'aller au contact justement
des raisons sans en faire une publicité
excessive mais enfin il me semblait
normal évident que d'aller se mettre
aussi à l'écoute pour comprendre les
raisons pour lequel il y avait eu cette
sortie ce qui d'ailleurs peut créer une
courbe qui peut diminuer parce que une
fois de plus pour remplir des objectifs
encore faut-il nommer des gens mais
encore faut-il aussi que les gens qui
sont nommés restent bien dans le cadre
des armées donc ça j'ai pas encore le
rendu de la mission sur lequel
d'ailleurs je vais jamais fait de
publicité mais l'occasion en effet de
vous de vous l'annoncer de vous le dire
parce qu'évidemment si on veut continuer
sur l'axe d'effort on ne peut pas ne pas
regarder aussi ce qui s'est passé ces
trois ou quatre dernières années en
effet des officiers généraux sont des
femmes ce qu'il faut se poser comme
question c'est quel en sont les raisons
vous souhaitez instaurer à
arbitrairement un quota de 15 pour de
15% pourquoi pas 50 vous manquez
d'ambition chers collègues plutôt que de
sortir du chapeau un pourcentage de
manière démagogique analysant plutôt les
raisons qui font que les femmes soient
insuffisamment nombreuses dans ces
fonctions afin d'y répondre et si
nécessaire d'y remédier faire un bon
officier ne dépend pas du genre ou de
l'origine cela dépend de la motivation
et des compétences à servir la France
vous justifiez cet amendement par
l'amélioration de la fidélisation de nos
troupes et de nos officiers les causes
de départ des militaires vers le privé
sont liés aux rémunérations et au fait
de trouver un emploi plus épanouissant
répondant à ses attentes comme le
propose notre groupe au lieu de chercher
à mettre en place des quotas homme femme
je vous remercie
après deux semaines de débats apaisés
les députés se prononcent en première
lecture sur le projet de loi de
programmation militaire place tout de
suite aux explications de vote et au
vote
plus qu'à une guerre d'avance cette loi
de programmation militaire nous expose
au risque au risque d'avoir une paix de
retard et c'est la raison pour laquelle
malgré des avancées notables pour nos
armées que nous avons souligné dans le
débat et les articles que nous avons
votés malgré cela les députés
communistes et GDR votre ont contre ce
texte et souhaite que se débat déborde
de l'Assemblée nationale pour que
l'ensemble de nos concitoyens s'en
saisissent pleinement c'est en
responsabilité que nous voterons ce
texte car il a le courage de porter des
choix l'état des finances il faut le
dire ne nous permet pas d'avancer
puissamment
mais le sérieux stratégique français
permet d'entretenir des armées d'emplois
qui sont jugés crédits par nos alliés
nos adversaires sans enthousiasme avec
vigilance mais aussi avec la
satisfaction de voir un certain nombre
de nos mesures adoptées nous voterons
pour cette loi de programmation
militaire avec il faut dire de
véritables morceaux de RN dedans mais
sans jamais oublier que le seul intérêt
qui nous anime c'est celui de la défense
de notre nation la France et de ceux qui
la font vivre arriver au terme du débat
je veux redire notre gratitude envers
nos soldats nous serons vigilants et
pressants pour que leur quotidien
s'améliore et les familles mieux
accompagnées il y a encore trop
d'incertitudes autour de l'avenir du
service de santé des armées et nous ne
comprenons pas pourquoi les avancées que
nous proposons pour les blessés
psychiques ont encore été écartés pour
toutes ces raisons nous voterons contre
je veux saluer la qualité de nos débats
elle tient la gravité de la matière
parce que dernière de décision il y a
des hommes des femmes qui se battent
parfois jusqu'à l'ultime sacrifice tout
au long de nos travaux j'avais en tête
un major du Commando Hubert qui sur la
plage arrière de la frégate aconit me
parler de deux de ses frères d'armes
tombés au Burkina Faso dans une
opération de libération de tâches
ensemble nous avons mesuré nous avons
murmuré la prière des parents celle de
l’espérance et anald mon Dieu donne-moi
ce dont les autres ne veulent pas en
pensant à lui je pense à la compagnie
des ombres qui nous a accompagnés tout
au long de nos débats celle de nos
collègues d'Abel ferry au colonel Driant
qui comme des millions de Français ont
fait le sacrifice de leur vie je pense
surtout à ceux qui sont tombés ces
dernières années à leurs frères d'armes
aux veuves aux orphelins
aux parents et à nos blessés qui luttent
contre la souffrance physique ou morale
je crois qu'en ayant débattu comme nous
l'avons fait et en votant aujourd'hui
cette LPM nous témoignons en toute
humilité merci le respect qui est dû à
ceux qui ont tout donné à la passion
reconnaissant de l'engagement sans
faille de nos militaires au service de
la nation le groupe démocrate votera
évidemment en faveur de ce texte et nous
vous invitons chers collègues à être
cohérents comme les 7 lois et à voter
également en faveur de cette LPM
historique je vous remercie notre vote
intervient à l'issue d'une première
lecture et l'examen de ce projet de loi
bascule désormais au Sénat nos collègues
du groupe socialiste vous ont déjà
transmis une série de plusieurs
questions nous serons particulièrement
attentifs à vos réponses au regard de
l'ensemble de ces éléments les députés
socialistes s'absciendront ne nous
voyons pas la face nous sommes
confrontés à des stratégies
d'affirmation de puissance accrues et à
de dangereux révisionnisme depuis le 24
février 2022 la guerre d'agression est
de retour sur notre continent de
nouvelles conflictualités se font jour à
l'est de l'Europe en Afrique et dans
l'espace indopacifique enfin la menace
terroriste n'a pas disparu loin de là
nous avons donc le devoir pour protéger
nos concitoyens de l'Hexagone comme des
Outre-mer de consentir cet effort
important pour nos armées c'est aussi la
garantie que la France restera un
partenaire incontournable en Europe et à
l'international le Groupe horizon et
apparenté approuvent pleinement cet
effort nécessaire et votre a donc sans
hésitation ce projet de loi de
programmation militaire je vous remercie
nous ne pouvons
pas tuer dans lequel s'inscrit cette
voie de programmation suite à
l'agression de l'Ukraine par la Russie
la guerre frappe à nouveau l'Europe hier
nous apprenions la destruction d'un
barrage en Ukraine un acte qualifié par
le Secrétaire général de l'ONU ont tenu
guteres de catastrophe humanitaire
économique et écologique monumentale dès
le début de l'invasion russe les
écologistes ont plaidés pour que la
France et l'Europe s'engagent
concrètement pour aider l'Ukraine à
maintenir sa souveraineté ce qui passe
notamment par l'envoi d'armes de
matériel de défense et de matériel de
secours ne vous y trompez pas les
écologistes n'ont pas à oublier leurs
engagements pacifistes et humanistes au
contraire lorsqu'il s'agit de faire face
à une agression militaire à des crimes
de guerre à l'attaque d'un autre crainte
contre nos valeurs et que tout un peuple
nous hésiterons pas à prendre
responsabilités et je suis sûr que cette
séance peut faire silence pendant une
minute au moins pour écouter ce que nous
avons à dire sur la Russie et sur
l'Ukraine et pour nos militaires alors
oui je vous le dis c'est dans un esprit
de responsabilité que les écologistes
ont travaillé sur cette loi de
programmation et je souhaite remercier
la capacité d'écoute et de débats dont
Monsieur le Ministre nous avons eu un
temps pour confronter nos analyses pour
exposer nos divergences cette loi
effectivement fait en plus plus 118
milliards d'euros sur 6 années en faveur
de l'armée oui c'est un besoin vital
nous ne le contestons pas mais des
besoins vitaux il y en a tellement et si
l'armée a besoin d'investissement nous
plaidons également pour qu'il y ait des
investissements dans l'ensemble des
autres besoins vitaux de notre état
l'école publique l'hôpital est bien
évidemment l'investissement pour la
transition écologique aujourd'hui vous
posez une loi de programmation des
finances publiques mais vous venez en
incapacité d'avoir une majorité pour
voter vos lois de règlement vous êtes en
incapacité pour avoir une loi de
programmation financière donc nous le
disons vous avez une solution pour avoir
une majorité elle se trouve dans les
investissements investissez autant dans
l'armée que dans l'école dans l'hôpital
dans la transition énergétique et vous
trouverez une majorité vous l'aurez
compris les écologistes voteront
responsabilité ils savent sera un grand
mais aujourd'hui il reste encore de
nombreux graisses sur cette voie de
programmation militaire
nous allons donc passer au vote je vais
donc mettre aux voix le projet de loi
tout le monde est évidemment à sa place
c'est un scrutin public
il a été annoncé le scrutin est ouvert
le scrutin est clos et voici le résultat
du scrutin
votant 548 exprimé 495 majorité 248 pour
408 contre 87 l'Assemblée nationale a
adopté
adopter une première fois à l'Assemblée
nationale puis au Sénat le texte fera
l'objet d'un accord entre les deux
chambres ce qui permet une adoption
définitive du Parlement le 13 juillet
veille de la fête nationale et du
traditionnel défilé militaire du 14
juillet un système numéro des grands
débats à très bientôt sur LCP pour une
autre séance
[Musique]